carmen is in los
angeles hi carmen welcome to the dave
ramsey show
hi dave and chris uh my question
hi my question is um my husband and i
are 62 years old and we would like to
relocate
to brentwood area in tennessee from
l.a and i would like to know
if what your thoughts are about us being
able to
retire we are raising
four grandchildren we've had them in our
home for the last five years
and last year we actually went ahead and
we adopted them
so uh we're emotionally and just
physically exhausted and my husband is
the one working full-time
i work a little part-time
and so we make about a hundred thousand
dollars
we are debt-free our home is worth
probably around seven hundred thousand
and we have a million dollars um in
in retirement and so and we have also
funded uh fifty thousand dollars uh
529s for each of the three excuse me
four
children how old are the kids
are five seven
eight and twelve wow so
if this is my husband and i retirement
would not even be
a problem you know we would know we
would have
this amount of money but when you have
four
children you don't know what the future
holds
and so um
i don't know um that is my question is
what are your
what do you mean you don't know what the
future holds you don't know what the
future holds if you retire
with no kids
what's the difference what is the what
is the uncertainty that four kids
adds to the future it's certain they're
all going to want to eat
it's certain they're all going to want
cars and it's certain they're going to
college and that's why you have a
college plan for them what's uncertain
the uncertainty is will our money lasts
oh you know two k you know okay
so if you invest a million dollars and
it makes um
10 or 12 percent in good mutual funds
yeah and you pull off eight percent
i'm just making this up and you left
some in there you didn't take it all out
it didn't take all out what it made okay
right eight percent of a million to be
eighty thousand
you sell your house in california by 700
thousand dollar house in tennessee
and you live in uh because you got a
paid for a house worth 700 in california
right
yes which means you're living in a
cracker box
right which means you're going to get a
raised car minnesota you'll get a really
nice house
compared to that i mean it's not it's
not a mansion but for 75 000 you can buy
a decent house in tennessee versus what
california costs so
uh i mean you're going to get a nicer
property and you got to live on 80 000
a year and feed these kids can you do
that
we can yes okay then the money would
never run out
because you're not touching the money
all you're doing is cashing the eggs
that the goose is like right don't get
into the goose
leave the goose alone live off the eggs
yep and make smart decisions moving
forward financially just like you guys
have been
you're out of debt you've got your house
paid off so you're not going to come
here and go backwards and take on a
mortgage why are you moving to tennessee
just
cost a living well cost of living
and just what the california schools
are kind of teaching the children um
we are we want to
just a little bit more less crazy like
lifestyle for them
okay that's fair okay a more traditional
setting for them a little less
correct might not be politically correct
in tennessee i'll just go ahead and warn
you
that's okay and we might not care if you
care
so i'll just go ahead and warn you some
of us are sensitive carmen don't let
dave scare you
uh some of us are sensitive yeah no
number in this room
but the uh yeah i'm kidding around with
you but yeah i completely agree with you
in other words and yeah it's a good move
here's the thing i heard and i want to
warn you against it all right you've
been through some kind of a tremendous
upheaval
in your family some kind of trauma
correct
and i kept
the uh the three-year-old the
five-year-old and the seven-year-old for
48 hours this weekend with my wife
and i'm exhausted and i got to send them
home
yes and you got to keep them the whole
time
so you said we're exhausted be careful
because when you're exhausted you're
prone to make bad decisions
because you feel entitled like i deserve
this
i took on these kids lord lord i did
this and so i deserve to go buy a car
on payments or i deserve to get
something i deserve to get this nice
thing
that i can't afford thing whatever the
thing is that i can't afford
but all of us have a tendency when we're
tired
to get entitlement fever and say i
deserve
i've said it chris has said it yep
everybody has said it at one time or
another and you are doing a
noble and a wonderful thing taking this
on i have no idea the circumstances you
didn't tell us we didn't ask
but there's some kind of a mess there
and you are taking
on a big old task you really are and i
want to tell you thank you on behalf of
these kids
i i don't know if anyone has told you uh
but what you all have taken on is a
major task but i want you to hear me
there's not an amount of stuff in there
that's going to make them kids happy
they need to be loved and they want your
attention and so
when you're 80 that five-year-old is
going to write a book about his hero the
grandmother
i still talk about mine and she's been
gone for 20 years
yep so you are changing lives with your
presence you and your husband both
just make sure you guys are staying
connected you and your husband working
on the friendship
get here get connected in with a good
church you can have a place to drop off
those kids
for about four or five days so y'all can
take a trip that's important
this is why baptist invented vacation
bible school i'm just saying
[Laughter]
it's a traditional value it really is
this really is they keep you sanity too